[Music]
brought to you by hulu time to have
great original shows and movies time to
have
hulu what's up party people welcome to
the honest trailers commentary for
nine
um i'm supposed to give it that system
it's nine
uh we're talking all things f9 uh our
behind the scenes thoughts our deleted
scenes um some questions and comments
from viewers like you and we'll tease
you with next week's honest trailer you
guys know the drill by now
oh what a long strange trip it's been
but actually pretty pretty consistent at
this point i feel like you kind of know
what you're getting from an f9 movie at
this point before we go on too long ryan
has let me know that we
don't worry we'll talk about the
spider-man trailer tomorrow i know
you're waiting for these tanks oh we've
got taped brother we got bone sauce
i i i feel like i won't even be able to
wait to share my tastes ah so many takes
so many takes oh i'm not on the
wednesday show y'all take care of that
you can sub in for me danielle it's fine
um
yeah we're talking f9 uh uh a little
late but but uh gave us some time to
reflect to really soak it in to really
enjoy we suck the juice out of this one
um
it was good
i feel like they really nailed the tone
on this one which is
so ridiculous so stupid so over the top
but like with a with such earnestness at
some moments that you can't you can't
really hate it it's like it's like the
parts that vin diesel wrote and then the
parts that like the screenwriters who
knew what they were doing wrote
it's like
it's going very well together i think
where this one failed it was in two
respects like just squash the beef
because it really could have used the
rock really could have used a little
hobs in here and um i think that the
action maybe because i didn't watch it
in a theater
nothing like nothing to write home about
nothing new nothing like i guess they
went to space but the space sequence was
not something
a good idea but the execution didn't
blow me away what are you guys overall
uh f9 thoughts so i did see it in the
theater and it is it was a
transformative experience um i saw it
with a huge group look there was a time
in spring when we all were in early
summer when we were like we're at the
house yay
and so we would do things like bring
groups of 30 [ __ ] writers to a
screening of a fast night and we didn't
like someone dressed up like a corona
bottle a lot of people in white tank
tops it was beautiful
so
i do think and even though i i was late
because i uh came with someone who i i
love him to death is perpetually late
for everything um but i don't have a car
so who am i to [ __ ] complain oh sorry
everybody gets one all you missed was
the opening uh los angeles nascar scene
yes which i which i which i caught in
subsequent viewing so it was great i do
agree it could have used the rock i
think that people would have popped
really hard for rock versus cena like i
think that would have been a huge thing
but this was a communal film and it was
like it felt like a celebration in the
theater and then watching it at home you
go oh this uh
it's got a lot of problems
this is there's a lot of but it's also i
don't know uh i at this point i'm so
hand wavy with these f9 or with the fast
and furious movies where i'm like no it
doesn't make sense but does it have to
but and we'll get into it i will say
that the movie commenting on itself was
the only time was like well don't remind
us of all the things that you did just
let it be ridiculous like don't remind
me that you're you're doing things that
don't make sense so that's kind of where
i stand with it but i liked it on a
whole it was just a better experience in
the theater or just lean into it and
make tyrese like an actual demi-god who
can't be harmed or something like he got
some sort of curse blessing that i i am
tyrese i am i cannot interfere i can
only comment
perfectly
any broad f9 strokes for us i mean i
think that yeah like i also saw it in
the theater and it was more fun in a
theater when you're just kind of caught
up in it i did think in the theater the
magnet chase where they they're when
they're really messing around with like
the dials and all the cards and
everything they're like flipping
throwing magnet stuff at one another and
then there's that really cool practical
shot where the car actually gets like
pulled through the building
into the the big whatever magnet bus or
what have you uh like i thought that was
really cool and i mean that still plays
at home but i i had the same general
reaction as danielle like watching it in
the theater i was like this rules and
then once you get it home i was like
okay like i also really don't like
i don't think i think it's better when
they play it completely straight like
when the drama and the emotion and the
character and the family stuff is
totally sincere
and
it's just we in the audience get to
recognize the ridiculousness of
everything that's what makes it fun and
i think they're they're a little bit too
much in the winky winky
elbow you in the ribs
kind of space here where it's like i
don't want tyrese to tell me that that's
what's funny
yeah i get it on my own i don't need
charlize theron to be like
here's the point in the movie where the
villain would do that no no you're in
the movie you be in the movie
i have like a bunch of tenants for what
makes a movie that is not like a great
movie but is a good movie to watch and
one of them is that it has to be sincere
and it can't be too winky at the
audience like that's like that's the
problem with snakes on the plane is that
like it just became a winking to the
audience it's like that's the problem
with the snark uh sharknado movies for
me it's like no it's got to be sincere
and there's got to be like some love in
it and there is love in this because we
all know how much vin diesel loves it
but it's also like y'all are getting too
close to
you you're icarus the meta commentary
around movies it's creeping in yeah yeah
i don't i don't think we want this
series to be like
smart and self-aware and like too cool
for school like that's there's plenty of
stuff that's doing that like like
deadpool can do that all day i want this
series to be like big dumb fun you know
yep yep so speaking of big dumb fun
let's play the honest trailer for f9
there was a time when people were like
oh this is the one where they'll go back
in time and kill hitler and it'll be f9
german vehicles driven off cliffs and
chow down in tokyo now after eight
movies they're out of ideas and we'll do
all that again
[Music]
plus go to space you said they should go
to space so they did a little space as a
treat dudes from the ghetto
outer space
fast nines
after corona put their coronas on ice
for a while our favorite family films
have returned just like a family now we
became a family it's for family family
family family and it's got everything
you'd expect from a new fest almond fake
deaths
pretty nifty magic trick some doomsday
device a prop guy picked up at target
what the hell is this and the annual
reveal of a new secret i feel like they
put even less effort than usual into
explaining what was at stake with the
device and what it could do
they don't do this movie one of the big
changes it brings to the whole franchise
is they are doing like the mission
impossible thing or the the bomb thing
but they're skipping the m scene like
there is no more like good morning mr
phelps your mission should you choose to
that's just over they just show up and
they're like hey we got a phone call and
we've already done all the things like
we got to go to you know yeah this place
then you're just there like they don't
take any time at all to set up what the
missions are gonna be it's called the
aries device you know like the god of
war if he has this he'll be the god of
everything that's all you get that's
literally all you get yeah
there's a satellite spencer there's a
satellite think of the satellite yeah
satellite and it's weird because it's
like well yeah i guess that saves you a
few minutes but it it it also one it
makes the movie really unmotivated
because that helps to motivate like when
you get bond going into m's office so
it's like okay that's the mission we
know what we got to do she's in charge
here we go and like and this is just
never they're just kind of like hanging
out they're like well we got this phone
call we think we should go here and it's
like what are you guys you've deputized
yourselves you're like international
cops now what is it i guess they are
yeah the the chain of command is like mr
nobody who
we never know who he works for or what
he does really
either the cia or a
shadowy cia esque organization he could
be completely rogue for all we know but
it's just like he
he was flying around with the magic
salad bowl and his plane crashed and
it's like well the only person he trusts
is dom doretto and han i guess well not
even doctor it was like taj and roman
like the only person he trusts is
uh that lady he met two movies ago
call me to chris yeah
ramsay her name's rand i always call
ludacris when i'm having problems also i
love the fact that like this is just me
getting into the weeds a little bit in
the movie that they go to a secret
hiding place that secret hiding place
gets found out and then they immediately
go back to that secret hiding place oh
that's turned on yeah they did return i
love that that made me want to do that
all right that's so good i like the
secret family member i'm here for the
team that crippled my brother you didn't
know one brother
that was my sister my name is my sister
jacob norman
how many relatives are these people
hiding 10 bucks says let he has an evil
twin by f11 i'm sorry
so pause that is from the film i believe
it's called the transition though i
think they they changed it from
something even worse um
somehow uh uh
stars her and sigourney weaver um in a
film about like a she
i think her name
it was fr her name's frank michelle
rodriguez's character's name is frank
and they give her an unwilling uh gender
transition surgery for some reason and
she has to get revenge and they're like
no this is actually like good and about
trans issues like we're really
addressing the subject spoiler alert
they are not
a very dumb 80s cokehead screenwriter
thought about what's funny is that i
wrote that joke without i mean i i
remember when that movie came out but i
was not thinking about that movie oh i'm
sorry it's called it's called the
assignment the assignment
when i wrote that joke they just that's
an editor just coming up with these
people oh i i i flagged that as like
we need to show um yeah show the
assignments let's let's not let that one
be lost to time
um maybe we'll do a well done spencer
movie night with that one anyway boy no
we should next watch along oh no
oh no
it's got uh michelle rodriguez tony
shalhoub uh come on
star stunned uh all right let's let's
keep going shalou will do whatever
you think i just like the whole time and
learn all about dom's secret brother
from another mother and possibly father
truly the only clue they're related is
the dramatic look back
and the mid scene grip flex
[Music]
they got that one from their dad
yeah
it's a whole school of acting that i
noticed in this film and i want to go
back to previous fast uh and see if the
forever tank tops dom toretto does this
is he will find a thing in the scene
that he can grip and just
he can just like really pop during the
scene like he'll always put his arms
down on the table or like you know to
the side or something like that and just
try to like bust out a try or uh or a
buy do we feel like he's awesome we feel
like he's also one of these guys that's
just hitting the ground i was just gonna
do a few push-ups before yeah just
before they shoot you know just to make
sure everything's
get real vascular you gotta get real
vascular we're gonna get that shrink
wrap hgh skin yeah yeah
that's nice um anyways very muscular
acting from everybody in this film uh
keep playing cena stars as dom's scorned
brother jacob who went from mechanic to
super spy before it was cool and now
that vin has finished teaching the rock
how to actually i'm sorry before
like we need to discuss the
the
psychological ramifications and just
this psychoanalyze
vin's casting of his younger self and
john cena's younger self i think it's
like a perfect window into how vin
diesel sees himself
uh and how he sees his inferior
wrestling co-stars because he casts
just like a hunky smart capable like
good-looking uh dude and then this just
absolute shrimp boat
of a little brother that they kept
flashing back to it was beautiful he is
noticeably tinier oh yeah the guy
playing young scene is a full like foot
shorter like he's supposed to be a
younger brother but a few years younger
not 10 years younger yeah
no it was absolutely great when we when
when we first flashbacked and realized
realized what was going on yeah they
don't look related then they don't look
related now
what's a reveal too in the flashback
that they're brothers right at first
there's just this younger guy around and
then you get that oh that's his brother
and you wouldn't put it together because
they do not look alike and one is a
whole lot tinier than the other one and
they they try to sell it in that scene
with helen mirren where she's like oh
yeah like it's a it's a similar chin no
it's not john cena has the most
distinctive chin in all of hollywood
it's not a similar anything and charlize
does that winking line too where she's
like i didn't notice a nordic strain in
the toretto bloodline apparently that's
like an easter egg that's like a it's
like a clue and there's gonna be like
more about that like through their mom
or something
so
we'll see maybe maybe cipher's their mom
who knows i also as a person who does
not look like any of her sisters it's
because we do not have all of the same
parents like i'm just saying that there
is literally no way that those two
people are have the same amount of the
same two people i know there is
definitely a terrific mom is so not in
like never mention
so not in the picture you know i could
you know i could turn this behind the
scenes doing this right now yeah they
could do uh two months that's that's two
new uh people to bring into the
franchise because they can still call
each other brothers they're half
brothers you know and then that opens
the door to more siblings cousins second
cousins
what if after fast ten we get all the
moms together helen mirren and whoever
like susan sarandon whoever they cast as
mama toretto whatever and they get a
fast mom's spin-off franchise we've had
the bad moms i want it yeah why not the
fast moms yeah i was just thinking fast
family reunion and it's like just a
cookout movie it's like just different
people pulling up
a mom
in the fast saga cardi b
finally we found the the franchise well
wait you're saying she's dumb she's
dom's mom no i'm saying she's about
she's a mom she's a real life mom so she
could be in our fast mom spring yes all
directed by tyler perry because if
you're gonna have a family reunion
their mr nobody is tyler perry yes yes
he's found a more submissive wrestler
who knows where he stands in the pecking
order i had to earn my way in and i'm
very grateful for that and bravo and
that choice fan cena won't cause any
trouble you can't see him and he can't
see taiwan
pause i love this because it's so
it's like
simultaneously embarrassing but
impressive like like he's been waiting
his whole life to for a moment to show
off that he knows mandarin chinese and
he has to do it to apologize for saying
you know uh uh does he does he speak
he's not doing somebody talking about
himself those exact words no he like uh
john cena i could talk about this for
hours he is a weird dude y'all
uh but not weird in a way where it's
like oh he's we know of weird things
he's done to people but weird in a way
where it's like
there's something real dark and i want
to know what it is
like he's he like he has like a moat in
front of his house uh after dinner
everyone has to dress up nice and then
all the men go to a cigar room and all
the women go somewhere else it's just
he's a weird dude
[Laughter]
yes mirrors above the bed he lives down
today
amazing
yeah everyone changes into their formal
jorts
cigars and brandy
i would love to go to somebody's house
and see the reactions where they were
like well all right then men are going
to retire to the parlor for brandy while
the lady's like i how would people react
that's the craziest thing i've ever
heard wow
yeah and just yeah that just you gotta
go hunt somebody for sport what's
happening
they're just gonna grow out just like
you know grow stuff cigars uh who's the
best kisser you know football stuff like
that or on the floor yeah
keep going
[Music]
when jacob has a fiendish plan to steal
the magic salad bowl that charlize
theron uses to cut her hair all your
favorites will return to stop them with
one glaring exception
and one small exception you probably
didn't notice
there's dom who's been practicing extra
hard on his driving face
thinking face hmm driving face
thinking face hmm
mia who picked up hacking in kung fu by
osmosis i think i can link into their
feed letty yeah
it's one thing for people to go from
like i guess criminal
street racers to super spies but
she's gone from
a lady who worked at a diner
she made sandwiches
bad sandwiches in the first movie she
didn't even have enough agency to change
the sandwich like
what uh what a glow up good for her good
friends we're all very proud of mia most
improved for sure oh my god yes it's
just i mean they all like they this
movie in particular i feel like they all
just like massively leveled up their
their skill sets you know like they
found like a huge like they raided a
dungeon and they found like a huge
treasure room and maxed out all of their
stats because like the tokyo drift guys
are building they were like they learned
to rock a tree off-camera yeah
you know this tank top gives plus 10 to
vitality yeah everybody is just like wow
they really improved a lot and all all
all around in just about every way and
we're about to talk about this so i
won't we won't play and pause real quick
but i love that um so it's like mia and
dom and little brian are on the farm and
they find out that like cipher's back
you know the world could be at stake and
uh letty doesn't hesitate to just like
she peels out instantly leaving dom with
this kid with a with a small child
uh well it is his shot sure sure sure
but then it takes a day of reflection
and then dom peels out it's gone so he
extensively left it with b and brian and
then mia is who also has two kids of her
own is like i thought i should tag along
to help save the world meaning that
brian is at home with three small
children all the responsible responsible
adults
are
risking their lives could all come back
dead and it'd just be my three my three
babies and brian just
it's
yeah
it's funny that it would be
between if it like obviously tragedy it
couldn't be brian we're all very sad
about it but
picturing the scenario of brian and mia
deciding who to go
it's like well you're the ex-cop who was
also living uh on the run as a criminal
expert street racer worked with the fbi
dom's partner in a bunch of these
ventures versus me
the lady who made the sandwiches
who should go and so i guess that's why
she had to pick up hacking and fighting
right right right you know she had to
she had a baby like yeah it's like don't
worry honey like i got this one you know
that's my turn on the chore chart really
working on hacking
ramsey sent me some friday ramsay sent
me some books so i'm working on it you
know good times good for her
lingo for hacking yeah yeah
keep going letty who doesn't hesitate to
pawn her stepson off on dom who doesn't
hesitate upon his own son off on mia who
doesn't hesitate to pawn her nephew off
on brian poor little hot potato the
tokyo drifters pause
i just want to talk a little bit about
that ramen scene in tokyo
i've i've rarely seen more obnoxious
fake eating in any movie like i gotta
re-watch that they're both yeah no just
they're both doing
terrible food work
they keep like first of all they're both
eating what looks like ramen with just
chopsticks none of the little spoons
sure they're not shaking it up so it's
like it's it's sub-optimal already
you're like that's a weird approach but
then they keep picking up one item from
their bowl holding it in the chopstick
and then putting it back in the bowl
without eating it and it's like that's
not how you eat food and food actually
has to go in your mouth and i know that
it's like a scene so you can't be
actually eating and talking but like why
even have the food there if you're not
gonna do convincing oh my god sorry i'm
watching this as you're talking this is
this is offensive how did we not
ramen is also like not ramen is not a
good i like i get it it's not a good
movie food it's not like you have to
like slurp and there's all this stuff
but it's like they were set up to fail
they were set up to fail have them have
sushi like sushi
this was exactly in my notes ramen the
worst the worst japanese movie food what
uh well
literally any other kind of japanese
food you could just pick up and eat and
then move on with your day they're both
just like very gently just
just putting their chopsticks up and
down in the bowl absolutely embarrassing
and it's like just have like a little
chicken cutlet or something and some
nice curry sauce that's delicious she
took a bite she took a bite uh um mia
took a bite me takes one bite
yeah i feel like she gets like a bear
she realizes what she's been doing and
it's like i gotta have at least one i
think she just took a bite of lettuce
[Laughter]
was so prominent in imax this was
bothering me and my roommates so much
this bothered me
so
much
it took me like a scene to get over how
much this bothered me
oh i love it okay yeah just like some
chicken like some kind of like a pot
sticker like there's far too much it
could be like a stock choice yeah
there's way too much greenery in there
the chat's naming options right now just
off the top of their heads thank you
i couldn't agree more there's so many
just like easy to eat and chat japanese
food yeah this is ridiculous
i'm looking at uh both beers uh still
completely full uh next to them at their
time i am so offended by the lack of
people drinking beer well that's just
moving rooker gets him a cold corona
opens it hands it to him diesel just
hangs onto it then sets it down yeah
doesn't take a single sip that's just
rude that's just rude a man handed you a
beer
like not even like a war like from the
fridge like special went and got
honestly this movie would make so much
more sense if they were drinking and
driving like if like before he does that
bridge jump he just chucked some beer
all right
it's like we're all listening we're
already
we're already taking some pretty big
odds so we might as well
oh man okay anyways keep going don't
drink something
these former rivals who've become an old
married couple so tootsie rolls is space
food
cause that's all you ate it's fat free
bro their former love interest who's
become a third wheel helen mirren who
has more sexual chemistry in five
minutes with dom than he has with
michelle rodriguez in the whole
franchise you're my favorite american
cipher the mysterious hacker who can
mysteriously change her clothes do her
makeup and take a dump in an empty
transparent cell and as the trailer
spoiled the return of han
why because fans want justice how well
um
uh let's see
okay sure got it
hit the nose again
i did not catch the first time when i
saw it in the theater that they used
holograms that i did not catch that
until until the second time through that
kurt russell explains that that's how
they were able to trick us into thinking
han was in the wreck when it exploded
yeah holograms if we can bring back
tupac we can get back on
holograms we can have han do hit him up
at coachella next next year
we have the technology i thought they
were gonna i assumed it was like they
had some there was like
there's like a hole like a manhole below
the wreck and he slid in there or
something i thought they were gonna have
some practical explanation not like oh
he just uh
projected a hologram underneath this car
wreck i guess
i hope that doesn't become like their
version of the mission impossible mask
is just like everyone's a hologram
although oh speaking of holograms
they've done this before have you been
on the universal ride yeah they said the
fact that you know i have babies of
course yes yes you got a hologram tyrese
you get i think hologram rock and diesel
um yeah no they they have all the crew
everybody they should have they should
have explained it in the movie
mr nobody rated universal studios for
their hologram technology
it's the hologram part's cool and then
you go into like a you know like a
tunnel where they project a screen or
something like that and it's just it's
the thing we did in the last trailer
where vin diesel is the same size as the
helicopter it's it's
really really off it's weird it's like
yeah the whole guy i can see how a fake
hologram death would would uh would
trick the eye to it would trick jason
statham i mean jason said it was very
close to the wreck so it's a very well
done hologram and he had no idea
look it's a lot of cameras and if it's
on rails i guess it makes sense at one
point my hair got wet i wasn't super
excited for that but
yeah i mean i guess it kind of if you
like look we can't if you squint it
makes sense and that's all i need from
my face yeah
sure fair enough
keep playing
this story is sick
hit that vape until f9's action scenes
start to make sense where cars can
outrun the landmines they drive over zip
lines go on for infinity
[Music]
except the one with a giant magnet on it
and leaving orbit in a pontiac figuero
doesn't immediately catch fire collapse
and explode when they crash into a
satellite at seventeen thousand miles
per hour
look i'm not asking for realism but the
intro to homeboys in outer space tried
harder danielle we found a way to get it
in
a spaceship answered
uh
the whole pilot's on youtube if you're
curious for uh what homeboys from outer
space would have could have been should
have been it's always been my dream to
somehow force homeboy i've seen every
episode of course i have
it's always been my dream to somehow
force it into any project i'm working on
uh thank you spencer was that was that a
upn a upn show i think yeah believe it
oh you know it oh you know it sounds
okay all right yeah good times all right
after what these films have become no
longer earnest action flicks about
street racing or so dumb their brilliant
heist movies no the franchise that was
good then bad then so bad it's good has
reached its final form so bad but they
think if they admit it you'll think it's
good we've taken out cars trains tanks
i'm not gonna even mention the submarine
and i ain't got one single scar to show
for you got a brother who also happens
to be some kind of super spy who
pre-planned an aerial jump and landed at
the bottom of an airplane mexico
no way no way no way
you're right if this was a movie this
would be the moment where the villain is
like
oh no
the moment that like really rode the
line between stupid and i loved it was
her uh yoda joke i love i loved i loved
it i loved it i did like i i enjoyed her
delivery of the yoga stuff yes yeah
that's how you get someone like charlize
for that part because you could really
really make that burn that was that was
excellent i mean i feel like i would
really hate this character if it wasn't
charlize play like she's what's making
cipher work at all for me because i
don't think conceptually it's a very
good character how do we feel about how
to see her
how do i feel about the bowl versus the
braids you know what it's better than
braids every day all day yeah bowl over
braids but i still feel like just just a
it's a it's a stage one rewrite you know
where are we going next though because i
feel like we need to escalate it's going
to be bangs it's all b-words okay
[Laughter]
all right keep going
quick someone toss it a corona
starring even more
car
funds
the last wrench hunter
john scenic route michelin rodriguez
gran turis bros
luda crash grow manual transmission
charlize trade in
mr no body shop han in 60 seconds auto
okay that was just too easy dodge ramsey
aston mirren
mia sorrento
and car db
car wars episode nine the phantom menace
so paws we're really running thin on car
puns we've done this for about
four or five of them at this point yeah
i think all of the ones i've worked on
the honest trailers for we've done car
puns yeah i wonder how long much like
the franchise i wonder how long we can
keep this going because we're really
scraping the bottom of the barrel here
yeah we're well i mean as long as they
keep adding new people we'll be all
right but we're running low on like and
we're running late
on star wars movies on on car wars uh
title things so it's true
i just wish that uh the american
versions kept their japanese titles
which is uh the whole fast and furious
thing is called wild speed and like the
they're called like wild speed sky
mission i wonder what this one was
called let's see one second f9 something
magnet maybe japanese laws of attraction
wild speed jet brick hell yeah yeah i
mean it's true
i mean they did the car had to go up on
it yeah that's fair they did a jet break
so well yeah the car jumps and then the
jet flies by and picks it up that might
be what they're referring to yeah
okay because they didn't want to spoil
space so yeah right right right where do
we do we think f10 will just go full
sci-fi back in time where are we i've
i've long said i felt like nine space
which we've
you know done we didn't really do it
though ten time travel i mean we went to
space more than you know branson went to
space yeah more than basically we're
counting richard branson then we should
count uh tej and roman yeah uh remember
he says vin says 11 will be the final
one right so i think 10 times he's
putting a two part 10 is like split and
then 11 and an end game yeah and then 11
multiverse i feel like that's that's
what you've got to do yes you do so 10
they've got to go back and stop
something in history from happening or
whatever like drive over hitler with the
car yeah and then uh and then 11 i feel
like they've got to it's either they've
got to fight like another parallel
reality's version of the toretto crew or
they have to go stop justin lin and
universal from making any more uh fast
films whoa that's full meta never have
yeah multiverse baby multiverse baby all
right
okay that's where you cross over with
jurassic park and you do the stuff
too but in the universal server instead
of the warner bros or transformers or
yeah you do something like that um you
just full-on space jam to it like dom
gets trapped inside the universal server
no not again
his way out little brian little brian's
really into video games
[Music]
there's some nuns there i guess and yogi
bear shows up i guess i don't know maybe
probably there are some all-time vin
diesel mumble growls in this movie to
the point where i just didn't really i
only caught like the final word of of
some of his lines it's just delivered
through a mouthful of gravel and um
bravo bravo sir there's also one point
we didn't mention in the honest trailer
but he i believe he pulls down a bill
yes he does with just the power of his
uh of his incredible arm his forearm
strength he just grabs some chains that
are attached to the roof of like
a like concrete tower yep it just pulls
it down that's amazing and there's also
so many times where he catches people by
like driving into them with a car and
that's not like a net
you're just hitting them with your car
they really think that the the hood of
dog's car is like a mattress and people
could just like just run into it and
they're fine
because like even in spider-man like you
go to save someone you still crack their
neck because physics yeah and so it's
like no i'm gonna drive this car into
you and then you'll be safe forever
right it's also just the idea that the
the hood of the car catches them instead
of them just hitting it
everybody's a little buzzed so they're
nice and relaxed
they just kind of fly just go limp yeah
they don't tense up
explains so much all right keep let's
let's wrap this up
pretty sad this is the last good thing
universal's got going for it enjoy these
before fast 10 has him driving through
jurassic park to fight the boss baby
yeah baby
um i'd watch it
so uh that that reminds me um
uh
lon you've done a herculean effort in
creating a a companion video that's also
out today uh where you actually
rewatched every fight scene or uh uh
between of the rock and of vending i
watched every every action scene from
every rock and vin diesel movie
and i counted up every every puncher hit
that they land against a foe every hit
or punch that they receive from a foe uh
and then their kills and their knockouts
we we compiled all these stats to
determine pound for pound punch for
punch movie for movie who actually is
doing the most damage on film the rocker
diesel yeah so probably i won't spoil it
but go no no
i was a little surprised by the results
it was not yeah and we're not what i
would have predicted we're we're uh
equalizing their their films made
because i think that vin is made more
than the rock so right we're doing it
with ratios yeah ratio so it's it's hits
landed like as a ratio for damage
received and it's knockouts per movie
kills per movie because right like the
rock has made more films you know you
you want to balance it out yep yep yep
so uh there's that and there's also the
fandom five trivia contest this friday
um 4 p.m pacific where you can answer
rick and morty questions for real money
and even if you don't know your answers
i think you still get some wendy's you
still get some wendy's there you go
spicy nuts spicy dogs a pickle rick um
so yeah and sauce though
uh come on come on hang out at that and
uh and and win some chow and some cash
uh also like and subscribe but you've
already all done that already right of
course you have um okay so we have some
outtakes let's see what we cut from this
masterpiece jacob is dom's brother where
do they even go from here tesh is
ramsay's uncle that he has an evil twin
just do 23 and me and get it over with
fam
prepare to go back in time but just a
flashback they won't drive a time
machine until fast 12. if this was a
movie this would be the moment where the
villain has an unexpected sent back
if i make the joke about it myself no
one else can make it also my mom says
anyone who bullies me is just jealous
okay
starring
dom torpedo
oldsmobile
ready set go
hondling
jordana crewster
and cardi baby
car wars
a new hobbs
pro tip if you've designed a super
weapon encrypting it with your own dna
is a terrible idea that means any bad
guy who steals it also has to kidnap you
or your family to use it you're
literally making your daughter a target
for global terrorism
amateurs
yeah well we don't want to put too much
thought into any of that stuff that's
yeah that's not what why would you do
that yeah that's what the movie does now
yeah now you need to cut off my head or
my hand in order to use the weapon like
well all right
if you say so
all right we've got some good questions
so let's uh let's let's roll through
these while we have time um aditya
agarwal asks what do you think hobbs was
up to during this movie's
events i think it's just just vibing in
samoa he totally just he just
reconnected with the samoan family and i
think he's taking uh some much needed
time off
to uh you know get uh get back in touch
with his roof yeah he was out he was out
paddling he couldn't be couldn't be
bothered
getting it on with shaw's sister which
as as movies have shown no one wants to
watch the rock make out with anyone so
he's doing it all off-screen yeah that's
why i was i was kind of shocked that you
said sister i thought he and shaw if you
if you just had a cutaway to them in a
hammock together like checking the phone
and then putting it back and then just
going rolling back over the sand like uh
yeah paradise lost it that'd be that'd
be my pick um
okay another a crucial question
unrelated but i want to i want to
address this
uh london rowlet asks uh can someone
please finally explain what ska is this
episode sincerely agenda
spencer do you want to pick it up pick
it up pick it up pick it up pick it up
see i i i'm probably the wrong person
answer this because i never liked scott
but i reached out to joe i dur i just i
mean i can i can walk you guys through
it if you want to walk us through the
basics joe didn't think he could explain
it in one episode so he
[Laughter]
it started in jamaica as an offshoot of
reggae it's just like kind of an
up-tempo sort of version of reggae
that's a little bit more like a rock if
they think of like uh you know a rock
band sort of vibe but playing more of a
reggae sound with horns
um
that was the first wave the second wave
was mostly from the uk it was bands like
the specials or the english beat or
madness so if you could think of songs
like house of fun or mirror in the
bathroom that second wave sky and then
third wave was what i got into when i
was a teenager in orange county in the
mid 90s and it was bands like no doubt
say ferris real big fish and it was that
movement of it was sort of like southern
california punk rock but mixed with
a bunch of horns because it was a bunch
of nerdy kids who were in marching band
in their high schools and they all knew
how to play the trumpet and the trombone
and they had friends playing rock music
and they were like let's put this
together and be obnoxious
i always describe it as reggae means big
band meets white kids yeah that's right
third wave sky was just like young white
suburban kids who were into punk who
also knew how to play trombone and
what's the difference between that and
like swing music
uh well swing is is ju the swing bands
were really just playing an updated
version of classic 30s 40s swing music
okay it wasn't like a hybrid of styles
really i mean in some minor ways but and
then what is what is it it was mostly
just
skanking is the kind of game
i wish i had enough room because i would
do it for you you kind of lean over and
you swing your arms a lot yeah he's
doing a better job of it than me oh boy
oh god if i if my hand if my arm wasn't
injured i would get up and just skank
for y'all cause i still you can look up
videos of people
yeah
i skank to this day
i have to stay back in the studio we're
gonna skank that's that's that's the
promise that's a promise skateboarding
and skankin which for people who keep
asking about that uh i don't know when
we'll be back we we have a studio
somewhere uh we just you know because of
the pandemic that keeps us keeps
happening it's closed our office is
closed um so
this fall maybe we'll see uh we'll let
you know um wear masks get vacations
wear masks and get vaccinated then we'll
be back in the studio
jeff beeler asks should helen mirren
become a full-time member of the fast
and furious family yes next question
yeah um
let's see uh jeffrey elverton asks i've
only seen the fast and furious movie so
all the first one so all my knowledge
comes from honest commentaries nice what
franchise have you completely missed out
on a whole franchise
i mean like i've never seen like high
school musical there's a few of those ya
ones i was gonna say like i haven't seen
any of the maze runners oh i've seen
divers
i've seen all those yeah i've seen the
first i've seen the first divergence and
that was enough for me i haven't seen
any any of those at all such an
abnegation thing but i watched all the
twilights so i feel good okay yeah i
haven't seen uh anything post twilight
one so oh
it's like they're so crazy it's like an
art film it's not even like a y.a
anymore the breaking dawns are so wild
it made me read the books because i was
like oh a werewolf falls in love with a
baby i have to read this if you were
like lars von trier made breaking dawn
too i'd be like yeah that that was right
i guess
amazing uh james bunt brings up i'm sad
you didn't go over the timeline in the
trailer hasn't it been just a few years
since tokyo drift and lucas black and
bow wow look like grandparents yes
that's i mean i can answer that question
that is correct yes i know we've done
timeline stuff in other honest trailers
for this franchise but that's a that's
an excellent point this is like
canonically a few years after tokyo
drift and it's been a rough few years
for those guys right yeah
just around all those rocket fumes like
ages that's just the length of time that
han has been gone which i think they say
is like five years right something like
that everybody use sunscreen
yeah
and they also learned they also learned
how to launch things into orbit safely
can i just throw that out there as well
like not only did they age a lot but in
a matter of a few years they've mastered
what entire teams that jpl and nasa do
they're really yeah and well we know
that bow wow can break the fourth wall
canonically also yeah it's true he's got
yeah he's got like dr strange yeah he
might be the the watcher of this whole
universe um okay so uh finally adam
halbert asks uh would you watch the
avengers fight the fast family or hit
two billion dollar franchises against
each other so who if you were to do a
franchise crossover war between the fast
family and blank you know who are you
going toe-to-toe with
like what oh transformers have them
performance yeah
like the thing that you love has to
fight you and so now it's like ah i have
to fight cars i have to fight a car but
i only but i love cars and so and then
they team up together yeah and then they
team up together i me you know what i
think i just want to watch bumblebee try
to crank down a beer is what it is
you know what might be fun would be
potter harry potter because they can
think
like magic versus the toretto crew we
haven't fully explored and like they've
even got like flying cars and like buses
that could change size
yeah so i mean imagine like a fleet of
magic cars but up against the
the power of toretto's driving it might
be you know oh man
give it give tyrese a wand yeah exactly
right
for like they're all in cars but he's
just hanging on to a fantastic beast of
some kind yeah he's on buck beak while
the rest of the murdered car this beer
has butter in it
i can't top that that's the pick
the magic world of harry potter and the
fast family um all right and then this
is a special request from uh jeffrey
yelvington asking if we can get a state
my statham impressive impression as i
tease next week's honest trailer there
you go
i'll just give this a show teasing our
next week's hottest taylor is good all
right here's what we're gonna do right
we're gonna take next week's on this
trailer and we're gonna we're gonna just
batter it we're just gonna beat it up
real nice and thoroughly we're gonna hit
it with our fist and we're gonna just
jam that fist right up it's underside
and just light it up and just go whoa so
that's your that's your clue
very good it's accurate
you should be able to get it from that
yeah um
and we will be back tomorrow for all of
danielle's thoughts about the spider-man
trailer
not it not it um
or i'll be there whatever some
combination of us will all be there and
eric sinister show up
so you come back too but not before
you've watched uh the rock versus uh
diesel by the numbers because it took
too long to do for long and uh and let's
uh let's all hang out the phantom five
and win some money together although we
are all uh exempt from competing but you
win some money and somebody's uh all
right we'll see you then bye-bye
this episode was brought to you by who
[Music]
you